i just saw something so horrific
so profoundly disturbing
so
rotten to the core something that would
make you want to jump out of a window
and i thought i should show it to the
audience take a look
[Music]
was that just the worst thing that
you've ever seen yeah that was terry
mcauliffe who is this really horrible
democrat who's running for governor of
virginia and of course he's calling the
other guy uh racist and all that he's
standing next to joe biden who's the guy
pretending to be president they don't
have masks on and just look at these
people dancing it's hard
[Music]
when was the last time
they're so human aren't they human the
way they move they're so human and they
like to dance it's just why did i do
that to you i've ruined your day i
thought my day was ruined why can't i
ruin everybody else's day absolutely
horrible but it was making me think you
know i often say how remember the orange
guy trump with the hair and everything
and the funny way he tweeted um he would
dance at a lot of his rallies and i
always would say that trump somehow
despite being a billionaire orange man
was more authentic than all of the
democrats if you just look at all of the
democrats they're so
deeply inauthentic all of the people who
are running last time whether it's biden
who doesn't know where he is or p buddha
judge who's just doing an impression of
obama or elizabeth warren i'm going to
get me a beer and she also pretended to
be native american to get a job like
these people are such frauds although i
will give bernie credit like he truly is
like an old socialist curmudgeon that is
bernie sanders there's no doubt about it
but i was thinking even trump dancing is
more authentic than these people
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tell me you don't miss that man with the
hand pumps and the pointing
the whole thing it's like that's him
dancing one more time just watch
mcauliffe
[Music]
all right all right enough of that
enough i i miss trump these people are
just all horrible